احنا واثقين في امكانيات عسكرنا واثقين في
قدرات ضباطنا واثقين في الشيء الموجود في
قروب الشعب السوداني تجاه القوات المسلحه
لذلك نحنا وهم سنظل سد منيع قدام هذا
العدو وده الحق الد يقيف مع الحق يجي يقيف
مع الحق الدار يمشي مع الباطل يمشي
وبيناتنا النقعه النقعه دي بيناتنا ما
عندنا حاجه ثانيه ولا عندنا كلام ثاني ما
في خليك كان نحتل احتلوها كل البلد دي
نحنا ما هنستسلم
ولا المقاومه حتجي ضدهم ولا حنقول ولا
حقدم لهم البلد دي في طبق البلد دي حق
السودانيين كلهم ما حق فئه ولا حقت مجموعه
واي زول تخيل ان هو ممكن يحكم من خلال
السلاح يقول انت كذاب وما بتقدر لو احتليت
السودان ده كله ما بتقدر الشعب السوداني
شعبي معلم وشعبي واعي وشعبي ما في ز بقدر
يظلمه في جزء من القوى السياسيه تتخذ
الدعم السريع كجناح عسكري واستخدمته الان
والان تدافع عنه وتتحدث بصوته نحن قول لهم
القوات المسلحه لن تسقط والشعب السوداني
لن يسقط سنقاتل لغايه اخر زول فينا احنا
كجيش ما قاعد نمشي نهاجم اصلا ما عندنا
قوه كده مش هاجمت لها مدينه الناس اللي
بيهاجموا المدن معروفين واللي بيهاجموا
القر معروفين والل بيقتلوا الناس معروفين
والبينه كل شي واضح العالم كله بيشوف فيهم
لكن نحنا كلنا عارفين انه هم قاصدين شنو
هم قاصدين يدمروا هذا الجيش نحنا نقول لهم
الجيش ده ما بي دمر حتى كان احتل السودان
ده كله الجيش ده حيكون قاعد وجزمته حتكون
موجوده في جو في صدور الرجال جوه في قلوب
الرجال حتكون جذوته موجوده وحيكون ارسه
وتقليده ده موجود ولو فضل واحد طلع هنا في
جارح البحر الاحمر دي الواحد لو فضل طلع
هنا ده الجيش السوداني ده ينبط من خلاله
وحيدا فع عن البلد وينتزع من كل زول داير
يستولى عليها او داير يشيله احنا بنطمن
الشعب السوداني بطمن كل ناسنا اللي شرفوا
ولا الدعايه وهبطوا من خلال الميديا انه
لو مدني دخل فيها العدو معناها البلد
انتهت ولا الجيش انتهى والله الجيش باعنا
والله الجيش ضيع ابدا هذه المعركه تحتاج
ان نتكاتف جميعا نتوحد جميعا نقف جميعا
صفا واحد حتى ندحر هذا التمرد ونقف جميعا
صف واحد حتى نضحك هذه الشائعات وهذا
الكلام اللي بحاولوا من خلاله يشتوا في
عرض القوات المسلحه يخض روحها المعنويه ذا
كان في مجموعه تخاذلت عن واجبها ما معناها
الجيش كله تخاذل ما معناها ان الجيش كله
نكس عن عهده في حمايه السودان والدفاع عنه
نحنا شوفنا في نياله هنا الناس قعدوا
بشهور بقاتل شفناهم في زالنجي والجنينه
بشهور قعدوا بقاتل دول القياده الان
ثمانيه شهور قاعدين يقاتلوا في امدرمان في
كل مكان في كل موقع الناس تقاتل لها
ثمانيه شهور تقاتل في ظروف صعبه متحملين
وصابرين لانه بفتكر انه دي امانه هم كلهم
يمكن يفنوا دوه عشان كده اح نقول الشعب
السوداني هذا الجيش موجود وسيظل هذا الجيش
موجود اي ي يقاتل مع الجيش يجي يقاتل
مواطنين اح شفناهم قاعدين الان بقاتل في
كل مكان وما شايلين السلاح وزودوا عن
البلد لانه عارفين انه الحصل ده حصل الحصل
ده ما في شي برا غير استعمار استعمار
السودان واستعمار الشعب السوداني من قبل
قوه عالميه وقوه اقليميه معلوم للناس ما
هي اهداف هذا التمرد اذا كان التمرد د
الدوله
56 شوفوا في الجنينه عمل شنو هناك في دوله
56 في الجنينه امش شوفوا ياله في دوله 56
هناك ومبارح الاموال الهبت والاسواق ما
خلوا فيها حاجه والنساء اللي اغتصبت دي 56
هذا حديث اريد به باطل نحنا نعلمه ونعلم
مقاصده نحنا بنكرر انه المساله دي ما
هتنتهي الا بالقضاء على هذا التمرد او
خروجه نهائيا من بلادنا من بلاد السودان
نحنا جزء كبير منه غير سوداني كلنا شفنا
في الميديا من كل دول الجوار الموجوده ومن
كل دول العالم في ناس قاعدين يقاتلوا فينا
هنا يقاتلوا في الشعب السوداني يقتلوا في
الشعب السوداني وينهب في الشعب السوداني
ويشيلوا حقه ووا في بناته السودانيين دي
كلهم عارفين من الممر وعارفين من المتخزن
وعارفين من متواطي وعارفين من بل فيهم
وبينه فيهم وبي في رواته عشان يجي يحكم
احنا بنقول ان والله احنا الروح اللي احنا
شفناها وشايفها عند هلنا السودانيين
والاحباط نقوللهم ما تياسوا هذه القوات
موجوده وكل جندي موجود في هذه القوات بدي
دوره وقوم بواجبه بامانه وقوم بواجبه
باخلاص ما في زول متردد ولا المتخاذل نحنا
ما بنخليه
والمتراجحات نحسب حساب عسير كم مش حساب
فيه تهاون ولا حساب فيه
مجامله
ه